في اوروبا لكن الان الى فرنسا حيث يتظاهر
الالا في انحاء البلاد رفضا لمشروع اصلاح
نظام التقاعد الحكوميه المثير للجدل وتنفذ
معظم القطاعات الحيويه اضرابا عاما يشمل
قطاعات النقل والطاقه والملاحه الجويه
والتعليم والصحه من فالنسيا انضم الينا
عبر الهاتف مراسل الجزيره لطفي المسعودي
لطفي لاول مره منذ عشر سنوات تتفق
النقابات العماليه على يوم احتجاجي كبير
كيف هي نسبه الاستجابه وكيف يبدو الوضع
لها
نعم وسيله النقابات ثمان الكبرى التي
اتفقت منذ عقد من الزمان لاول مره على
الدعوه الى الاضراب والى تعبئه العامه
لمشروعي الحكومه في اصلاح الصناديق تقول
ان كسبت اختبار الناس واثبتت ان الحكومه
يعني مشروعها هذا لا تلد الى دعم شعبي وهي
ترفض الارقام التي تسوقها وزاره الداخليه
على ان محمد المتظاهرين هنا في العا
الفرنسيه باريس وفي حدود 80000 وتقول ان
هذا الرقم
يتجاوزوا الرقم الذي قدمته وزاره الداخليه
في اضعاف
من المفترض وسيدها ان تكون هذه المظاهره
قد انطلقت منذ اكثر من ساعه ونصف الان من
ساحه الجمهوريه باتجاه ساحه الامه
ولكن تاخد انطلاقها لماذا لان الشارع
الرابط بين الساحتين مليء همم
وجميع الانود والشوارع المحيطه بتاعه
جمهوريه مديها في المتظاهرين جميع
النقابات وهناك الادب حتى صحبه عائشه
تنتهي بالحكومه بانها المتصدر في هذا
العرض الذي تعاني منه صناديق الاجتماعيه
عبر اصلاحها الاول الذي بدات تنفيده عامين
وتعالى
الرئيس مطران في ولاياته الاولى وتكون ان
الحل في اصلاح وقت السنه في خلق
الاجتماعيه هو التراجع عن الاصلاحات التي
وكذلك اثرازه عن مشروع اصلاح قانون انظمه
التقاعد التي يعني تاريخها همم
ان تبقي الى كاهله للفرنسيه الذي هو في
حاجه لنيل قصب من الراحه بعد سنوات من
العمل والخروج الى تقاعد في سنه 60 تختلف
عليه سن الرابعه والستين يعني هنا كما
يقولون ان الحكومه هي من انصار الراسماليه
المتوحشه وتريد
حتى من قصه قليل من الحياه بعد سنوات
طويله لذلك هم يعتبرون ان صفهم من ادم
الذي ابدى اليوم من خلاله هذه العادات
الكبيره
العاصمه الفرنسيه
يبقى الان ماذا سيكون رد الحكومه رئيسه
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه غير موجود في فرنسا
هذا هو موجود في اسبانيا وتم قده بشده
قالوا انه في يوم من ذهب كان من المفروض
ان يكون الرئيس موجود على الاقل على تراب
الفرنسي احتراما للهاء لهذه الجماهير
الفرنسيه من العمال التي تعبر عن رايها في
ربه سياسه يعتبرون انها سياسه يعني من باب
الترخيص عليهم وهم من يسمعون ثوره فرنسا
وهم يعني الثوره الحقيقيه همم فرنسا همم
بالنسبه للاضراب يقولون ان الاستجابه يعني
تتوقعات اكثر من 70% من المدربين في
المؤسسات التعليميه همم في مطافي النسبه
تتراوح بين 70 و100% في النقل العموميه
وقد شاهدنا هذا هنالك القطارات التي تداول
يعني في عمومي فرنسا
غير في فرنسا بالنسبه للاتصالات الرابطه
بين المدن لم ابدا اليوم وكذلك بالنسبه
للقتال العاديه قطار فقط من بين كل عشره
يعني امن نقل المسافرين في فرنسا اليوم
همم بالاضافه الى اعلام النقابات النقابات
العاملين في محطات في توليد الطاقه
النوويه وكذلك اعتقد الكهرومائيه يقولون
انه تم التخفيده في نسبه توبه الكهرباء
الفرنسيه يوميا همم للكهرباء ويلوحون في
هذا الحكومه الى لم تستجد في صوت الشارع
الذي عبر بقوه لهذا القانون سوف يكون لهذا
الاضراب لماذا بعد مثلا نقابه هذه العمل
الشغل في في النقل الحديدي همم ضبطت موده
السادس والعشرين من يناير الاستئنا في
الاضراب وكذلك السادس الى نبته
كده ماكينه الحكومه تعتمد على يعني فصل
همم 49 ثلاثه من اجل تمرير همم يعني
قوانينها ومشاريها قوانينها في البرلمان
فانهم سوف يصرون على موقفهم من رفض على
نطفي المسعودي مراسلنا من باريس